something you may not know about me is
that I adore power wash simula obsessed
with it my only complaint is that you
know there's something missing I've
never really felt like I'm really power
washing until today with power wash
simulator VR on meta Quest 3 the amount
of times that I've washed this van to
try to get the achievement and it still
feels different here in the flesh get
right around the edges here you got to
make sure you get those nooks and
crannies the gloss is always the hard
pot on this one it's the thing that
slows you down don't have any of my
extensions yet takes me back to the good
old days when I was just starting out in
this career like honestly I cannot
express to you quite how much I find
power wash simulator to be like one of
the most soothing experiences available
to the human mind and now I don't even
have to look at the real world like come
on beautiful look at me go well this is
how I'm spending the rest of my year